أجنبية ،
هذه هي أصوات الروس ، زوجات الآباء والأمهات
والأشقاء الذين يبحثون بيأس عن
إجابات
تدعو للعثور على أي معلومات عن
الجنود الروس الذين فقدوا الاتصال
بهم أو الذين يقاتلون في أوكرانيا والذين قد يكونون
مصابين في الأسر أو حتى قتلوا
هذه الزوجة الروسية مثل كثيرين آخرين قد
تحولوا إلى  مصدر غير مرجح
لمساعدة الأوكرانيين
في مبنى الحكومة الأوكرانية
كريستينا وهو اسمها المستعار
مسؤول عن خط ساخن يسمى العودة
من أوكرانيا على قيد الحياة والذي
تقول وزارة الداخلية الأوكرانية إنه تلقى أكثر من
6000 مكالمة
طلبت كريستينا ألا نظهر
وجهها  يتم غزو البلد ولكنك
تشعر أيضًا بالحاجة إلى مساعدة هذه
العائلات الروسية
الأجنبية
هذا
الحي السكني يمكنك أن ترى
أنه الآن
فقط كيف تحطمت آه حياة
العائلة هنا
كانت
تبدو أعني
أن النوافذ لديها كل شيء.  لقد تم تفجيرها ، من
الواضح أن
جميع ممتلكاتهم قد تركت
وراءها لأنهم قد
اختفوا نوعًا ما ،
وهناك صورة
يبدو أنها
موجودة في بعض الأشخاص الذين
عاشوا هنا ، كانت عائلة بها بعض
الأطفال على ما يبدو
و  لقد نجوا من هذا الأمر ، وهو أمر جيد
ولكن بالطبع
عندما تنظر إلى الوضع
والطريقة التي يقصف بها الروس
المناطق السكنية في جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
لذلك لم ينج الكثير من الناس ،
هذا مثير للاهتمام ، تعال وإلقاء نظرة
، إنه الأطفال  غرفة نوم
يمكنك رؤيتها هنا ،
انظر إلى
الأسرة المكونة من طابقين
هنا مع السقف الذي سقط
على الجزء العلوي منها عندما
سقطت تلك القذيفة
وبالطبع في حالة
الذعر وفي الإخلاء ترك الأطفال
كل ألعابهم
هنا
تعلمون
ويظهر لك فقط
أنه بغض النظر عن مكان وجودك
في هذا البلد حيث تهاجم روسيا
البلدات والمدن عبرها
، يتم تحطيم الحياة